at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking can I ask you a personal
question no I must - any organism living
tissue over metal endoskeleton this
episode is brought to you by LegalZoom
which more than 2 million Americans have
used to help start their businesses past
guests even such as while WordPress lead
developer CEO of automatic Matt
Mullenweg
now valued at more than a billion
dollars have used LegalZoom to help with
their business needs specifically in his
case
to form his company but LegalZoom isn't
just for launching your business their
services include everything from helping
you to manage changing tax laws
reviewing contracts creating NDA's
non-disclosure agreements important
stuff handling lease agreements and
assisting with really any other legal
challenge hurdle inconvenience that
typically takes time and effort away
from running your business the best part
is that you won't get charged by the
hour
because LegalZoom isn't a law firm so
they won't be running the clock up and
spinning circles just to raise your bill
instead they just ask you to pay one low
upfront price for whatever it is that
you're looking to get Alucard style
so visit legalzoom.com and check out
their business section for all their
services and if you want special savings
that's the terminology and the copy that
they suggest I don't know what the
special savings is folks but it's
titillating if you want special savings
enter promo code Tim T I am at checkout
capital T lower case I am again take a
peek legalzoom.com and enter promo code
Tim
I get asked all the time if you could
only use one supplement what would it be
and my answer is inevitably athletic
greens it is your all-in-one nutritional
insurance I recommended it in the 4-hour
body did not get paid for that and I
travel with it to avoid getting sick I
take it in the mornings to ensure
optimal performance it just covers all
my bases if I can't get what I need
through whole food meals throughout the
rest of the day if you want to give
athletic greens to try they are offering
a free 20 count travel pack for
first-time users I always travel with at
least three or four of these this
represents a $100 value so if you buy
athletic greens you get an extra $100
and free product so check it out
athletic greens calm forward-slash Tim
again that's athletic greens calm
forward-slash Tim for your free travel
pack with any purchase hello boys and
girls this is Tim Ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the Tim Ferriss show
this is an experimental episode and my
guest so to speak is someone I've known
for quite a long time now Sam Harris Sam
Harris you may know the name received a
degree in philosophy from Stanford
University and a PhD in neuroscience
from UCLA he's the author of many
best-selling books including the end of
faith letter to a Christian nation the
moral landscape free will lying waking
up and Islam in the future of Tolerance
a dialogue which he co-authored he also
hosts the popular podcast waking up with
sam harris you can find him on twitter
at sam harris org
that's har ris sam harris org and on the
web at sam harris dot org but this
episode came about because sam asked me
somewhere between six and nine months
ago to be a beta tester for a new app he
was creating and ostensibly it was a
meditation app it's called waking up and
you can find it at waking up calm which
i highly recommend i anticipated it
would be good because sam is always good
he's one of those rare humans who very
irritably
seems to think and speak in finished
prose he also has a voice one of the few
voices that can put you into a semi
psychedelic state while you were
completely
sober and if that makes no sense it will
make sense experientially once you get
to the end of this episode in any case
there are some great apps out there for
different purposes among them oak made
by my friend Kevin Rose for meditation
also Fantastic Sams approaches a little
different and as he puts it in the audio
that you're going to listen to in part
he says you do not have to be the best
at anything to be almost uniquely
qualified for something he has a very
unusual combination of experiences and
areas of expertise and his particular
approach here is that of a progression
and what I like is that there's a
logical progression 1 2 3 white belt
yellow belt etc in terms of layering on
different types of training for learning
the skill of meditation and it's really
an experience of exploring consciousness
he also gets into quite a bit more I
talked about his experiences with MDMA
his spiritual exploration god forbid to
it I did there in India contact with
so-called gurus dueling masters the goal
is the path duality versus non duality
and there are a lot of gems within that
you can apply to business your personal
life etc because guess what the
precursor to all of this is your mind
and consciousness so learning how to
hone the mind and your perceptions is
really paramount to mastering on some
level everything else if you want to
just jump to the meditations and lessons
that he presents you can jump to but 47
minutes after he starts and those of you
who are even more impatient I'm going to
be publishing a companion episode to
this immediately after this one so think
of it as simultaneously if you go back
to where you got this podcast you'll
find a shorter one say 10 or 20 minutes
I'm not sure exactly how long that will
take you through meditations and lessons
I did one meditation first thing in the
morning and one lesson in the late
afternoon to wind down that's how I
approached it so that you can just hit
play and jump immediately into guided
meditations
and they will offer different approaches
to give you a flavor in any case the
lessons themselves will jump into
thinking about death the mystery of
being and in the companion episode the
logic of practice this is a somewhat
dense episode I encourage you to stick
with it if it's too tough if you find
yourself wandering in the mind which of
course you're going to be training in a
sense against then you can jump to
minute 47 after Sam starts for the
meditations or you can go to the
companion episode in either case i
really suggest checking out waking up
calm that is the app itself i've no
financial stake nothing to gain
other than recommending you to a tool
that i've found to be incredibly
powerful and that is shared by some
people I also respect greatly who are
beta testers like dr. Peter Atia who's
also been on the podcast so without
further ado that was a lot of a deal but
I think necessary context please enjoy
this exploration of your own mind and
consciousness with Sam Harris hello Tim
Ferriss fans this is Sam Harris of the
wakin up podcast and now the waking up
course which is a app that just released
on iOS and soon to be on Android and my
friend Tim has very generously invited
me onto his podcast to preview this
course for you and to speak a little bit
about meditation and I'm very happy to
do that
first a warning in addition to just
talking about the course and about
meditation Tim has asked me to preview a
few of the guided meditations from the
app so parts of this podcast won't make
for very good listening in the car or at
the gym or while multitasking to get
value from these sections and to not be
bored by the periods of silence you
really need to be paying attention so if
you're not in that situation now you
might save this whole podcast for
another time I'll let you know when I'm
dropping them in and how long they are
so if you insist on listening to this
while you are kite surfing or hacking
some government installation or
staggering around South by Southwest and
full ketosis or whatever it is that the
average Tim Ferriss fan does on a day
like today you will be ok ok so I'm
going to talk for a while about what I'm
attempting to do with this course and
why I've released it as an app
there are several meditation apps out
there and many of them are quite good
there's calm and headspace and my
friends Dan Harris and Joseph Goldstein
have the 10% happier app Tim's buddy
Kevin rose as the oak app these apps
really are quite good and they will
definitely teach you how to meditate and
while I cover similar ground in the
waking of course it's not just a
meditation app I'm attempting something
else too but before I get into the app
first let me tell you a little bit about
my background for those of you who are
not familiar with it I got into
meditation at the end of my sophomore
year in college just when I turned 20
and this was on the heels of a
psychedelic experience that provided a
fairly startling firmware upgrade of my
mind I've written about psychedelics and
supportive and also in fairly cautionary
ways especially in my book waking up
actually there's a there's a main
chapter on that topic that's available
both in print and an audio on my website
under the title drugs and the meaning of
life in fact
tim has not only referenced it on this
podcast but I think the audio is
available in one of his earlier podcasts
and I'll say a few words about how I
view the difference between psychedelics
and meditation in a minute actually I
think I should just read you the first
few pages of my book waking up because
it gives the full context about how I
came to this topic and how I think about
the nature of mind and the role that my
experience with psychedelics played here
and also how I came to the practice of
meditation so here's how the book begins
was participated in a 23 day wilderness
program in the mountains of Colorado if
the purpose of this course was to expose
students to dangerous lightning and half
the world's mosquitoes it was fulfilled
on the first day what was in essence a
forced march through hundreds of miles
of backcountry culminated in a ritual
known as the solo where we were finally
permitted to rest alone on the outskirts
of a gorgeous alpine lake for three days
of fasting and contemplation I had just
turned 16 and this was my first taste of
true solitude since exiting my mother's
womb it proved a sufficient provocation
after a long nap and a glance at the icy
waters of the lake the promising young
man I imagined myself to be was quickly
cut down by loneliness and boredom I
filled the pages of my journal not with
the insights of a budding naturalist
philosopher or mystic but with a list of
the foods on which I intended to gorge
myself the instant I returned to
civilization
judging from the state of my
consciousness at the time millions of
years of hominid evolution had produced
nothing more transcendent than a craving
for a cheeseburger and a chocolate
milkshake I found the experience of
sitting undisturbed for three days amid
pristine breezes and starlight with
nothing to do but contemplate the
mystery of my existence to be a source
of perfect misery for which I could see
not so much as a glimmer of my own
contribution my letters home in their
plaintive nests and self-pity rivaled
any written at Shiloh or Gallipoli so I
was more than a little surprised when
several members of our party most of
whom were a decade older than I
described their days and nights of
solitude in positive even
transformational terms I simply didn't
know what to make of their claims to
happiness
how could someone's happiness increase
when all the material sources of
pleasure and distraction had been
removed at that age the nature of my
mind did not seem to interest me only my
life did I was utterly oblivious to how
different life would be if the quality
of my mind were to change our minds are
all we have they're all we've ever had
and they're all we can offer others this
might not be obvious especially when
there are aspects of your life that seem
in need of improvement when your goals
are unrealized or you're struggling to
find a career where you have
relationships that need repairing but
it's the truth
every experience you have ever had has
been shaped by your mind every
relationship is as good or as bad as it
is because of the minds involved if you
are perpetually angry depressed confused
and unloving
your attention is elsewhere it won't
matter how successful you become or who
is in your life you won't enjoy any of
it most of us could easily compile a
list of goals we want to achieve or
personal problems that need to be solved
but what is the real significance of
every item on such a list everything we
want to accomplish to paint the house to
learn a new language to find a better
job
is something that promises that if done
it would allow us to finally relax and
enjoy our lives in the present
generally speaking this is a false hope
I'm not denying the importance of
achieving ones goals maintaining one's
health or keeping one's children clothed
and fed but most of us spend our time
seeking happiness and security without
acknowledging the underlying purpose of
our search each of us is looking for a
path back to the present we're trying to
find good enough reasons to be satisfied
now acknowledging that this is the
structure of the game that we're playing
allows us to play it differently how we
pay attention to the present moment
largely determines the character of our
experience and therefore the quality of
our lives mystics and contemplatives
have made this claim for ages but a
growing body of scientific research now
bears it out
a few years after my first painful
encounter with solitude in the winter of
1987
I took the drug three for
methylenedioxypyrovalerone us at dance
clubs and raves in the 1990s at the time
I didn't know anyone of my generation
who had tried it one evening a few
months before my 20th birthday a close
friend and I decided to take the drug
the setting of our experiment bore
little resemblance to the conditions of
Dionysian abandon under which MDMA is
now often consumed we were alone in a
house seated across from each other on
opposite ends of a couch and engaged in
quiet conversation as the chemical
worked its way into our heads
unlike other drugs with which we were by
then familiar marijuana and alcohol
MDMA produce no feeling of distortion in
our senses our minds seemed completely
clear in the midst of this ordinariness
however I was suddenly struck by the
knowledge that I loved my friend this
shouldn't have surprised me he was after
all one of my best friends however at
that age I was not in the habit of
dwelling on how much I loved the men in
my life
now I could feel that I loved him and
this feeling had ethical implications
that suddenly seemed as profound as they
now seem pedestrian on the page I wanted
him to be happy that conviction came
crashing down with such force that
something seemed to give way inside me
in fact the insight appeared to
restructure my mind my capacity for envy
for instance the sense of being
diminished by the happiness or success
of another person seemed like a symptom
of mental illness that had vanished
without a trace
I could no more have felt Envy at that
moment than I could have wanted to poke
out my own eyes
what did I care if my friend was better
looking or a better athlete than I was
if I could have bestowed these gifts on
him I would have truly wanted him to be
happy
made his happiness my own a certain
euphoria was creeping into these
reflections perhaps but the general
feeling remained one of absolute
sobriety and of moral and emotional
clarity unlike any I had ever known it
would not be too strong to say that I
felt saying for the first time in my
life and yet the change in my
consciousness seemed entirely
straightforward
I was simply talking to my friend about
what I don't recall and realize that I
had ceased to be concerned about myself
I was no longer anxious self-critical
guarded by irony in competition avoiding
embarrassment ruminating about the past
and future or making any other gesture
of thought or attention that separated
me from him I was no longer watching
myself through another person's eyes
and then came the insight that
irrevocably transformed my sense of how
good human life could be I was feeling
boundless love for one of my best
friends and I suddenly realized that if
a stranger had walked through the door
at that moment he or she would have been
fully included in this love love was at
bottom impersonal and deeper than any
personal history could justify indeed a
transactional form of love I love you
because now made no sense at all
the interesting thing about this final
shift in perspective was that it was not
driven by any change in the way I felt I
was not overwhelmed by a new feeling of
love the insight had more the character
of a geometric proof It was as if having
glimpsed the properties of one set of
parallel lines I suddenly understood
what must be common to them all the
moment I could find a voice with which
to speak I discovered that this epiphany
about the universality of love could be
readily communicated my friend got the
point at once all I had to do was ask
him how he would feel in the presence of
a total stranger at that moment and the
same door opened in his mind it was
simply obvious that love compassion and
joy in the joy of others extended
without limit the experience was not of
love growing but of its being no longer
obscured love was as advertised by
mystics and crackpots through the ages a
state of being how had we not seen this
before and how could we overlook it ever
again
it would take me many years to put this
experience into context until that
moment I had viewed organized religion
as merely a monument to the ignorance
and superstition of our ancestors but I
now knew that Jesus the Buddha Lao Tzu
and the other saints and sages of
history had not all been epileptic
schizophrenics or frauds I still
considered the world's religions to be
mere intellectual ruins maintain that
enormous economic and social cost but I
now understood that important
psychological truths could be found in
the rubble
okay so that's how I started my book
waking up which is a book about the
nature of consciousness and how we can
understand some of the life-changing
experiences people can have experience
is often described as mystical or
spiritual but understand them in a 21st
century rational scientific context as
some of you probably know I've been a
fairly vociferous critic of religion
over the years I've written several
books and participated in many debates
spelling out the reasons why my basic
view is this there's a difference
between believing things for good
reasons and believe in things for bad
reasons and this is a difference that we
all recognize in every area of our lives
until the conversation turns to things
like God and what happens after death
and the origins of certain books like
the Bible and the Quran my argument is
that we can get was most profound out of
human life without lying to ourselves or
to our children about the nature of
reality that's not to say that the
universe might not be incredibly strange
or the science has everything figured
out in fact the universe is incredibly
strange and science does not have
everything figured out but one thing
should be absolutely clear the men and
women who live 2,000 years ago didn't
have everything figured out either and
on many crucial points they were
ignorant of things that every child
learns in school today okay like for
instance that brains are somehow
involved in producing minds
no one knew this 2,000 years ago and to
deny it today
is intellectually irresponsible
so after I had the experience on MDMA I
just described I spent the better part
of my 20s seeking out a fairly esoteric
education it wouldn't have been so
esoteric in the 60s when many people
were dropping out and going to India
with the Beatles but it was fairly rare
to see someone my age doing this in the
late 80s
so most my friends at the time were 20
years older than I was and I made many
trips to India and Nepal to study with
various meditation masters I spent
around a year and a half or two years on
silent retreat never for longer than
three months at a time that was spread
out over my 20s I did a couple of
three-month retreats and several
two-month retreats and one-month
retreats and many shorter ones mostly in
the context of practicing of apana
otherwise known as mindfulness
meditation but ultimately practicing
zouk Chan which is a Tibetan practice
that I'll talk about in fact I should
just read you another section in my book
waking up because I spell out some
important distinctions there there's a
distinction
generally speaking between gradual
versus sudden notions of realization or
awakening and this can seem totally
paradoxical to people so I'm gonna read
you a little bit about this and you'll
get more of my background here
this from a section in the book titled
gradual versus sudden realization
we wouldn't attempt to meditate or
engage in any other contemplatively
didn't feel that something about our
experience needed to be improved but
here lies one of the central paradoxes
of spiritual life because this very
feeling of dissatisfaction costs us to
overlook the intrinsic freedom of
consciousness in the present as we have
seen there are good reasons to believe
that adopting a practice like meditation
can lead to positive changes in one's
life but the deepest goal of
spirituality is freedom from the
illusion of the self and to seek such
freedom as though or a future state to
be attained through effort is to
reinforce the chains of one's apparent
bondage in each moment traditionally
there have been two solutions to this
paradox one is to simply ignore it and
to adopt various techniques of
meditation in the hope that a
breakthrough will occur some people
appear to succeed at this but many fail
it is true that good things often happen
in the meantime we can become happier
and more concentrated but we can also
despair of the whole project the words
of the sages may begin to sound like
empty promises and we're left hoping for
transcendent experiences that never
arrived or proved merely temporary the
ultimate wisdom of enlightenment
whatever it is cannot be a matter of
having fleeting experiences the goal of
meditation is to uncover a form of
well-being that is inherent to the
nature of our minds it must therefore be
available in the context of ordinary
sight sound sensations and even thoughts
peak experiences are fine but real
freedom must be coincident with normal
waking life
and as a sidebar to this this note me
speaking off-book this is one of the
crucial distinctions between meditation
and psychedelics as tools it's very easy
to draw the lesson from psychedelic
experiences however useful that freedom
somehow lives in radically transforming
the contents and character of
consciousness whereas the goal of
meditation is to recognize that there's
something about ordinary consciousness
the very awareness in you that is
experiencing the sound of my voice in
this moment there's already radically
free of self it's already open it's
already undefined consciousness never is
truly confined by its content and so
while psychedelics have been very useful
for me and many others the center of the
bullseye for me is something that is
actually coincident with normal waking
consciousness right precisely the kind
of consciousness that could allow you to
safely drive a car right which if you've
ever taken acid or mushrooms it's not
where one tends to be pitched on those
drugs so back to the text
other traditional response to the
paradox of spiritual seeking is to fully
acknowledge it and concede that all
efforts are doomed because the urge to
attain self transcendence or any other
mystical experience is a symptom of the
very disease we want to cure there is
nothing to do but give up the search
these paths may appear antithetical and
they're often presented as such the path
of gradual ascent is typical of tera
vaada Buddhism and most other approaches
to meditation in the Indian tradition
and gradualism is the natural starting
point for any search spiritual or
otherwise such goal-oriented modes of
practice have the virtue of being easily
taught because a person can begin them
without having had any fundamental
insight into the nature of consciousness
or the elusiveness of the self he need
only adopt new patterns of attention
thought and behavior and the path will
unfold before him by contrast the path
of sudden realization can appear
impossibly steep it is often described
as quote non-dualistic because it
refuses to validate the point of view
from which one would meditate or
practice any other spiritual discipline
consciousness is already free of
anything that remotely resembles a self
and there is nothing you can do as an
illusionary ego to realize this such a
perspective can be found in the Indian
tradition of Advaita Vedanta and in a
few schools of Buddhism those who begin
to practice in the spirit of gradualism
often assume that the goal of self
transcendence is far away and they may
spend years overlooking the very freedom
they yearn to realize the liability of
this approach became clear to me when I
studied under the Burmese meditation
master SIA Dow open DITA a SAN through
several retreats with open data each a
month or two in length these retreats
were based on the monastic discipline of
tera vaada and Buddhism we did not eat
after noon and were encouraged to sleep
no more than four hours each night
outwardly the goal was to engage in 18
hours of formal meditation each day
inwardly it was to follow the stages of
insight laid out in Buddha Gauss's fifth
century treatise the Vasudha manga and
elaborated in the writings of upon death
his own legendary teacher maja CCL the
logic of this practice is explicitly
goal-oriented according to this view one
practices mindfulness not because the
intrinsic freedom of consciousness can
be fully realized in the present but
because being mindful is a means for
attaining an experience often described
as quote cessation which is thought to
decisively uproot the illusion of the
self along with other mental afflictions
depending on one stage of practice
cessation is believed to be a direct
insight into an unconditioned reality in
pali this is called Nibbana in sanskrit
nirvana that lies behind all manifest
phenomena this conception of the path to
enlightenment is open to several
criticisms the first is that it is
misleading with respect to what can be
realized in the present moment in a
state of ordinary awareness thus it
encourages confusion at the outset
regarding the nature of the problem one
is trying to solve
it is true however that striving toward
the distant goal of enlightenment as
well as the nearer goal of cessation can
lead one to practice with an intensity
that might otherwise be difficult to
achieve
I never made more effort than I did when
practicing under who pandita but most of
this effort arose from the very illusion
of bondage to the self that I was
seeking to overcome the model of this
practice is that one must climb the
mountain so that freedom can be found at
the top but the self is already an
illusion and that truth can be glimpsed
directly at the mountains base or
anywhere else along the path one can
then return to this insight again and
again as one's sole method of meditation
thereby arriving at the goal in each
moment of actual practice
this isn't merely a matter of choosing
to think differently about the
significance of mindfulness it is a
difference in what one is able to be
mindful of dualistic mindfulness paying
attention to the breath for instance
generally proceeds on the basis of an
illusion one feels that one is a subject
a locus of consciousness inside the head
that can strategically pay attention to
the breath or to some other object of
awareness because of all the good that
it will do this is gradualism in action
and yet from a non-dualistic point of
view one could just as well be mindful
of selflessness directly to do this
however one must recognize that this is
how consciousness is and such an insight
can be difficult to achieve however it
does not require the meditative
attainment of cessation another problem
with the goal of cessation is that most
traditions of Buddhism do not share it
and yet they produce long lineages of
contemplative masters many of whom have
spent decades doing nothing but
meditating on the nature of
consciousness if freedom is possible
there must be some mode of ordinary
consciousness in which it can be
expressed
why not realize this frame of mind
directly nevertheless I spent several
years deeply preoccupied with reaching
the goal of cessation at least one year
of that time was spent on silent retreat
although I had many interesting
experiences none seemed to fit the
specific requirements of this path there
were periods during which all thoughts
subsided and any sense of having a body
disappeared what remained was a blissful
expanse of conscious peace that had no
reference point in any of the usual
sensory channels many scientists and
philosophers believed that consciousness
is always tied to one of the five senses
that the idea of quote pure
consciousness apart from seeing hearing
smelling tasting and touching is a
category error and a spiritual fantasy I
am confident that they are mistaken but
cessation never arrived
given my gradualist views at that point
this became very frustrating most of my
time on retreat was extremely pleasant
but it seemed to me that I had been
merely given the tools with which to
contemplate the evidence of my non
enlightenment my practice had become a
vigil a method of waiting however
patiently for a future reward
the pendulum swung when I met an Indian
teacher named hwl Punja called pooja-ji
or Papaji by his students pooja-ji was a
disciple of ramana maharshi arguably the
most widely revered Indian sage of the
20th century brahmanas own awakening had
been quite unusual because he had had no
apparent spiritual interest or contact
with a teacher as a boy of sixteen
living in a middle-class family of South
Indian Brahmins he spontaneously became
a spiritual adept while sitting alone in
his uncle's study ramana suddenly became
paralyzed by a fear of death he lay down
on the floor convinced that he would
soon die but rather than remaining
terrified he decided to locate the self
that was about to disappear he focused
on the feeling of I a process he later
called self inquiry and found it to be
absent from the field of consciousness
Ramana the person didn't die that day
but he claimed that the feeling of being
a separate self never darkened his
consciousness again
after fruitlessly attempting to behave
like the ordinary boy he had once been
brahmana left home and traveled to
Tiruvannamalai an ancient pilgrimage
site for followers of Shiva he spent the
rest of his life there in proximity to
the mountain Arunachala with which he
claimed to have a mystical connection in
the early years after his awakening
Ramana seemed to lose his ability to
speak and he was said to grow so
absorbed in his experience of
transfigured consciousness that he
remained motionless for days at a time
his body grew weak developed sores and
had to be tended by the few locals who
had taken an interest in him after a
decade of silence around 1906 Ramana
began to conduct dialogues about the
nature of consciousness until the end of
his life a steady stream of students
came to study with him these are the
sorts of things he was apt to say these
are quotes from Ramana Maharshi
the mind is a bundle of thoughts the
thoughts arise because there is the
thinker the thinker is the ego the ego
if saw it will automatically vanish
here's another quote reality is simply
the loss of the ego destroy the ego by
seeking this identity because ego is no
entity it will automatically vanish and
reality will shine forth by itself
this is the direct method whereas all
other methods are done only retaining
the ego no sadness spiritual practices
are necessary for engaging in this quest
and finally here's one more quote there
is no mystery greater than this that
being reality we seek to gain reality we
think that there is something hiding our
reality and then it must be destroyed
before the reality is gained it is
ridiculous a day will dawn when you will
laugh at your past efforts that which
will be on the day you laugh is also
here and now back to my text any attempt
to make sense of such teachings in third
person scientific terms quickly produces
monstrosity x' from the point of view of
psychological science for instance the
mind is not just a quote bundle of
thoughts and in what sense can reality
be quote simply the loss of the ego does
this reality include quasars and
hantavirus but these are the kinds of
quibbles that will cause one to miss
from Ana's point
while the philosophy of Advaita is
that's the word for non-dualism in
Sanskrit while the philosophy of advisor
and Romano's own words may tend to
support a metaphysical reading of
teachings of this kind their validity is
not metaphysical rather it is
experiential the whole of Advanta
reduces to a series of very simple and
testable assertions consciousness is the
prior condition of every experience the
self or ego is an illusory appearance
within it look closely for what you are
calling I and the feeling of being a
separate self will disappear
what remains as a matter of experience
a field of consciousness free undivided
and intrinsically uncontaminated by its
ever-changing contents these are the
simple truths that pooja-ji taught in
fact he was even more uncompromising
than his guru in his non duality whereas
ramana would often concede the utility
of certain dualistic practices pooja-ji
never gave an inch the effect was
intoxicating especially to those of us
who had spent years practicing
meditation poon gigi was also given to
spontaneous bouts of weeping and
laughter both apparently from sheer joy
the man did not hide his light under a
bushel when I first met him he had not
yet been discovered by the throngs of
Western devotees who would soon turn his
tiny house and Lucknow into a spiritual
circus like his teacher ramana poon did
she claimed to be perfectly free from
the illusion of the self and by all
appearances he was and like ramana and
every other Indian guru who knew she
would occasionally say something deeply
unscientific on the whole however his
teaching was remarkably free from Hindu
religious 'ti or unwarranted assertions
about the nature of the cosmos he
appeared to simply speak from experience
about the nature of experience itself ku
energies influence on me was profound
especially because it came as a
corrective to all the strenuous and
unsatisfying efforts I'd been making in
meditation up until that point but the
dangers inherent to his approach soon
became obvious the all-or-nothing
quality of poon gg's teaching obliged
him to acknowledge the full
enlightenment of any person whose
grandiose or manic enough to claim it
thus I repeatedly witnessed fellow
students declare their complete and
undying freedom all the while appearing
quite ordinary or worse in certain cases
these people had clearly had some sort
of breakthrough but poon G's insistence
upon the finality of every legitimate
insight led many of them to delude
themselves about their spiritual
attainments some left India and became
gurus from what I could tell Punch eg
gave everyone his blessing to spread his
teachings in this way he once suggested
that I do it and yet it was clear to me
that I was not qualified to be anyone's
guru nearly twenty years have passed and
I'm still not of
from punta g's point of view this is an
illusion and yet there simply is a
difference between a person like myself
who is generally distracted by thought
and one who isn't and cannot be i don't
know where to place poon GG on this
continuum of wisdom but he appeared to
be a lot farther along than his students
whether punta she was capable of seeing
the difference between himself and other
people
i do not know but his insistence that no
difference existed began to seem either
dogmatic or delusional on one occasion
events conspired to perfectly illuminate
the flaw in poon juji's teaching a small
group of experienced practitioners among
us several teachers of meditation had
organized a trip to india and nepal to
spend ten days with poon GG in Lucknow
followed by ten days in Katmandu to
receive teachings on the Tibetan
Buddhist practice of zou Chen as it
happened during our time in Lucknow a
woman from Switzerland became quote
enlightened in poon GG's presence for
the better part of a week she was
celebrated as something akin to the next
Buddha who entered you repeatedly put
her forward as evidence of how fully the
truth could be realized without making
any effort at all in meditation and we
had the pleasure of seeing this woman
sit beside poon GG on a raised platform
expounding upon how blissful it now was
in her corner of the universe she was in
fact radiantly happy and it was by no
means clear that poon Gigi had made a
mistake in recognizing her she would say
things like there is nothing but
consciousness and there's no difference
between it and reality itself
coming from such a nice guy lawless
person there was little reason to doubt
the profundity of her experience when it
came time for our group to leave India
for Nepal this woman asked if she could
join us because she was such good
company we encouraged her to come along
a few of us were also curious to see how
her realization would appear in another
context and so it came to pass that a
woman whose enlightenment had just been
confirmed by one of the greatest living
exponents of advaita was in the room
when we received our first teachings
from two corrigan rinpoche who was
generally thought to be one of the
greatest living zouk ten masters of all
the Buddhist teachings those of xoJane
most closely resembled the teachings of
advaita the two traditions seek to
provoke the same insight into the non
duality of consciousness but generally
speaking only zouk Jen makes it
absolutely clear that one must practice
this insight to the point of stability
and that one can do so without
succumbing to the dualistic striving
that haunts most other paths at a
certain point our discussions with two
Corgan our swiss prodigy declared her
boundless freedom in terms similar to
those she had used to such great effect
with punchy after a few highly amusing
exchanges during which we watched cuckoo
Oregon's struggle to understand what our
translator was telling him he gave a
short laugh and looked the woman over
with renewed interest how long has it
been since your last lost in thought he
asked I haven't had any thoughts for
over a week the woman replied to
Corrigan smiled a week yes no thoughts
no
my mind is completely still it's just
pure consciousness that's very
interesting
okay so this is what's gonna happen now
we're all going to wait for you to have
your next thought there's no hurry we're
all very patient people we're just gonna
sit here and wait so please tell us when
you notice a thought arise in your mind
it is difficult to convey what a
brilliant and subtle intervention this
was it may have been the most inspired
moment of teaching I have ever witnessed
after a few moments a look of doubt
appeared on our friends face
okay wait a minute oh that could have
been a thought there okay over the next
30 seconds we watch this woman's
enlightenment completely unravel it
became clear that she had been merely
thinking about how expansive her
experience of consciousness had become
how it was perfectly free of thought
immaculate just like space without
noticing that she was thinking
incessantly she's been telling herself
the story of her enlightenment and she
had been getting away with it because
she happened to be an extraordinarily
happy person for whom everything was
going well for the time being this was
the danger of non dual teachings of the
sort that pooja-ji was handing out to
all comers it was easy to delude oneself
into thinking that one had achieved a
permanent breakthrough especially
because he insisted that all
breakthroughs must be permanent what the
Sojin teachings made clear however is
that thinking about what is beyond
thought is still thinking and a glimpse
of selflessness is generally only the
beginning of a process that must reach
fruition being able to stand perfectly
free of the feeling of self is the start
of one's spiritual journey not its end
I think I'll read one more section here
because this will give you more context
for how I think about meditation the
next section here entitled zouk Jen
taking the goal as the path to KU organ
Rinpoche lived in a hermitage on the
southern slope of shivapuram mountain
overlooking Kathmandu Valley he spent
more than 20 years of his life on formal
retreat and was deservedly famous for
the clarity with which he gave the quote
pointing out instruction of zou Chen the
formal initiation in which a teacher
seeks to impart the experience of self
transcendence directly to a student I
received this teaching from several Seok
Jin masters but I never met anyone who
spoke about the nature of consciousness
as precisely as to Corrigan in the last
five years of his life I made several
trips to Nepal to study with him the
practice of zouk jinn requires that one
be able to experience the intrinsic
selflessness of awareness in every
moment that is when one is not otherwise
distracted by thought wishes to say that
for as ochin meditator mindfulness must
be synonymous with dispelling the
illusion of the self rather than teach a
technique of meditation such as paying
close attention to one's breathing as
ocean master must precipitate an insight
on the basis of which a student can
thereafter practice a form of awareness
the Tibetan term is Rig be' that is
unencumbered by subject object dualism
thus it is often said in zou Chen that
one quote takes the goal as the path
because the freedom from self that one
might otherwise seek is the very thing
that when practices the goal of zou Chen
if one can call it such is to grow
increasingly familiar with this way of
being in the world
in my experience some so Chen masters
are better teachers than others I've
been in the presence of several of the
most revered Tibetan Lamas of our time
while they were ostensibly teachings
ochen and most of them simply described
this view of consciousness without
giving clear instructions on how to
glimpse it the genius of two horrigan
was that he could point out the nature
of mind with the precision and
matter-of-factness of teaching a person
how to thread a needle and could get an
ordinary meditator like me to recognize
that consciousness is intrinsically free
of self there might be some initial
struggle and uncertainty depending on
the student but once the truth of
non-duality had been glimpsed it became
obvious that it was always available and
there was never any doubt about how to
see it again I came to to Oregon
yearning for the experience of self
transcendence and in a few minutes he
showed me that I had no self to
transcend in my view there's nothing
supernatural or even mysterious about
this transmission of wisdom from master
to disciple took Oregon's effect on me
came purely from the clarity of his
teaching as it is with any challenging
endeavor the difference between being
utterly misled by false information
being nudged in the general direction
and being precisely guided by an expert
is difficult to overstate the direct
perception of the optic blind spot
provides a useful analogy imagine that
perceiving the blind spot will
completely transform a person's life
next imagine that whole religions such
as Judaism Christianity and Islam are
predicated on the denial of the blind
spots existence let us say that their
central doctrines assert the perfect
uniformity of the visual field perhaps
other traditions acknowledge the blind
spot but purely in poetical terms
without giving any clear indication of
how to recognize it a few lineages may
actually teach techniques whereby one
can see the blind spot for oneself but
only gradually after months and years of
effort and even then when glimpses of it
will seem more a matter of luck than
anything else in a more esoteric
tradition still a quote blind spot
master gives the quote pointing out
instruction but without much precision
perhaps he tells you to close one eye
for reasons that are never made explicit
and then says that the spot you seek is
right on the surface of your vision no
doubt some people will succeed in
discovering the blind spot under these
conditions but the teacher certainly
could be clearer than this how much
clearer
- Corrigan had been pointing out the
blind spot he would have produced a
figure like the one below and given
these instructions and then I have the
classic image you would use to glimpse
your own blind spot of a fixation cross
on one side and a large dot on the other
and then I give the instructions here
I'll just read them through it and
remind you about how clear this could be
one hold this figure in front of you at
arm's length - close your left eye and
stare at the cross with your right three
gradually move the page closer to your
face while keeping your gaze fixed on
the cross for notice when the dot on the
right disappears five once you find your
blind spot continue to experiment with
this figure by moving the page back and
forth until any possibility of doubt
about the existence of the blind spot
has disappeared is considered bad form
in most spiritual circles especially
among Buddhists to make claims about
one's own realization however I think
this taboo comes at a high price because
it allows people to remain confused
about how to practice so I will describe
my experience plainly before meeting -
Corrigan I had spent at least a year
practicing of a pasta on silent retreats
the experience of self transcendence was
not entirely unknown to me I could
remember moments when the distance
between the observer and the observed
had seemed to vanish but I viewed these
experiences as being dependent on
conditions of extreme mental
concentration consequently I had thought
that they were unavailable in more
ordinary moments outside intensive
retreat but after a few minutes
- Corrigan simply handed me the ability
to cut through the illusion of the self
directly even in ordinary states of
consciousness this instruction was
without question the most important
thing I've ever been explicitly taught
by another human being it has given me a
way to escape the usual tides of
psychological suffering fear anger shame
in an instant
at my level of practice this freedom
lasts only a few moments but these
moments can be repeated and they can
grow in duration punctuating ordinary
experience in this way makes all the
difference in fact when I pay attention
it is impossible for me to feel like a
self at all the implied center of
cognition and emotion simply falls away
and it is obvious that consciousness is
never truly confined by what it knows
that which is aware of sadness is not
sad that which is aware of fear is not
fearful the moment I am lost in thought
however I'm as confused as anyone else
given this change in my perception of
the world I understand the attractions
of traditional spirituality I also
recognize the needless confusion and
harm that inevitably arise from the
doctrines of faith-based religion I did
not have to believe anything irrational
about the universe or about my place
within it to learn the practice of zou
Chen I didn't have to accept Tibetan
Buddhist beliefs about karma and rebirth
or imagine the two corrigan or the other
meditation masters I met possessed magic
powers and whatever the traditional
liabilities of the guru devotee
relationship I know from direct
experience that it's possible to meet a
teacher who can deliver the goods okay
so that's the end of my reading so
that's how I come to the practice of
meditation
and after I spent the decades of my 20s
largely focused on meditation as well as
reading the relevant Eastern and Western
philosophy I decided to go back to
school because I was writing nonfiction
about the nature of the mind
happily I had dropped out of Stanford
University where you can never really
drop out
I think Stanford is one of the few
schools in the United States that has
the policy of never making you reapply
so I just showed up like some Rip Van
Winkle character after 11 years away and
finished my degree in philosophy and
then went on to do a PhD in neuroscience
a UCLA
so I bring a philosophical and
scientific and secular perspective to
meditation
ultimately I think we should all be
practicing non-dual mindfulness without
believing any [ __ ] that is a human
future worth wanting
and that's what I'm attempting to equip
people to do in the waking of course in
producing the wake and of course I'm
attempting to do something that I am
especially qualified to do man I don't
consider myself the best at any one
thing but you don't have to be the best
at anything to be almost uniquely
qualified for something the week and of
course is in part a meditation course so
obviously there are guided meditations
don't be continually adding to those as
time goes on I would say that even if
you're an experienced meditator using
guided meditations can be extremely
helpful and this is one of the things
that's unique about audio you can't do
this with a book there's no alternative
to having an actual voice remind you
that you're supposed to be paying
attention and I find guided meditations
extremely helpful and I've been
meditating for now nearly 30 years
in addition to the guided meditations
there's also an expanding curriculum of
short talks on a variety of topics I
call these talks lessons some explain
concepts that are directly relevant to
meditation others are more like
philosophical interventions or have you
reflect on a specific topic for a few
minutes sometimes starting with a
scientific finding or quotation that
inspires a particular line of thought so
here I'd like to give you a taste of the
course I'll start with one of the early
meditations very much designed for
someone new to the practice of
mindfulness so if you're not bored
already this is the part of the podcast
that really will bore you to tears if
you're working out of the gym or
commuting but if you're in a spot where
you can meditate here's the first
10-minute meditation
[Music]
once again take a seat either in a chair
or cross-legged on a cushion it's good
to sit as comfortably as you can and
it's usually best to be sitting as
straight as you can now close your eyes
and become aware of the sensations of
sitting feel your arms at your sides and
perhaps take a few deep breaths
just allow gravity to settle you into
your seat now as you did yesterday
become aware of the sensations of
breathing notice where you feel the
breath most clearly either at the tip of
the nose or the rise in falling of your
abdomen or chest it doesn't matter where
you pay attention to the breath
and you can change your focus from
session to session if you like but for
the moment just pick one spot and focus
there
there's nothing especially significant
about the breath but it's something you
always have with you and it's as good as
any other sense object as a basis for
training your powers of attention
eventually the practice will incorporate
everything that arises in consciousness
just feel the mirror sensations of
breathing from the beginning of the
inhalation to the pause between breaths
and follow the exhalation
to the end
trying to cover the breath with your
awareness and once again there's no need
to control your breathing just let it
come however it comes
what we're doing here is sharpening the
only tool you really have your mind this
is what you take with you in any
situation in life this is what
determines how you respond to emotional
stress and physical pain and every other
difficulty you encounter this is the
basis for every decision you make and
every interaction you have with other
people and as you begin to observe it
you'll notice perhaps with growing
amazement that your mind is totally out
of control
and as you try to pay attention to the
breath you'll begin to notice that the
primary obstacle to your paying
attention is thinking thoughts
continually arrives and you forget that
you're even trying to meditate at all
and this happens over the course of mere
seconds just try to count the next 10
breaths without getting distracted you
can silently in your mind count one on
the inhalation and one again on the
exhalation and then to see if you can
get to 10
unless you have a lot of concentration
you probably were unable to tell how
precarious your awareness of the breath
actually was how your attention was
being buffeted on all sides by
discursive thought now the goal isn't to
stop your thoughts or to suppress any
emotion that might arise along with them
it is rather to notice these mental
events clearly and to experience them
fully more fully in fact to recognize
them as appearances in consciousness
the moment they arise but that is
generally a very difficult thing to do
in the beginning so for the time being
the moment you discover that you're
thinking just observe it and come back
to the breath
in this final minute of the meditation
just start again
just feel the next breath as it comes
okay
just take a moment to take stock of how
you're feeling whether you're tired or
restless or calm whether your experience
was Pleasant or unpleasant isn't really
the point what you're learning here is a
new skill and unless you're coming to
this course already knowing how to
meditate you can't expect to be able to
do it well in the beginning as the
practice develops over the next days and
weeks you'll see that you do less not
more than you normally do you're not
adding an artifice to your experience in
the present moment rather you're simply
becoming less distracted the purpose of
meditation is to discover what your mind
is like when you're no longer
perpetually identified with the contents
of your thoughts and to make progress
you simply need to be willing to begin
again
[Music]
okay so that's what an early guided
meditation sounds like now I'll give you
a lesson and these are again these are
short talks on many different topics
here's one on the topic of death
[Music]
well today's topic is a topic we all
think about while doing our best not to
think about it
the topic is death and how we think
about death changes depending on whether
we're thinking about dying ourselves or
about losing the people we love but
whichever side of the coin we take here
death is really an ever-present reality
for us and it is so whether we're
thinking about it or not it's always
announcing itself in the background on
the news in the stories we hear about
the lives of others in our concerns
about our own health in the attention we
pay when crossing the street
if you observe yourself closely you'll
see that you spend a fair amount of
energy each day trying not to die and
has long been noted by philosophers and
contemplatives and poets death makes a
mockery of almost everything else we
spend our lives doing just take a moment
to reflect on how you've spent your day
so far the kinds of things that captured
your attention the things that you've
been genuinely worried about think of
the last argument you had with your
spouse think of the last hour you spent
on social media over the last few days
I've been spending an inordinate amount
of time trying to find a new font for my
podcast this has literally absorbed
hours of my time so if you had stopped
me at any point in the last 48 hours and
asked me what I'm up to what really
concerns me what deep problem I'm
attempting to solve
the solution which seems most likely to
bring order to the chaos in my corner of
the universe the honest answer would
have been I'm looking for a font now I'm
not saying that everything we do has to
be profound in every moment I mean
sometimes you just have to find a font
but contemplating the brevity of life
brings some perspective to how we use
our attention it's not so much what we
pay attention to it's the quality of
attention it's how we feel while doing
it and if you need to spend the next
hour looking for a font you might as
well enjoy it because the truth is none
of us know how much time we have in this
life and taking that fact to heart
brings a kind of moral and emotional
clarity and energy to the present or at
least it can and it can bring a resolve
to not suffer over stupid things we take
something like road rage this is
probably the quintessential example of
misspent energy you're behind the wheel
of your car and somebody does something
erratic or they're probably just driving
more slowly than you want and you find
yourself getting angry now I would
submit to you but that kind of thing is
impossible if you're being mindful of
the shortness of life if you're aware
that you are going to die and the other
person is going to die and that you're
both going to lose everyone you love and
you don't know when you've got this
moment of life this beautiful moment
this moment where your consciousness is
bright where's it's not dimmed by
morphine in the hospital on your last
day among the living
and the Sun is out or it's raining both
are beautiful and your spouse is alive
and your children are alive and you're
driving and you're not in some failed
state where civilians are being rounded
up and murdered by the thousands you're
just running an errand and that person
in front of you who you will never meet
whose hopes and sorrows you know nothing
about but which if you could know them
you would recognize are impressively
similar to your own it's just driving
slow this is your life the only one
you've got and you will never get this
moment back again and you don't know how
many more moments you have no matter how
many times you do something there will
come a day when you do it for the last
time you've had a thousand chances to
tell the people closest to you that you
love them in a way that they feel it and
in a way that you feel it and you've
missed most of them and you don't know
how many more you're going to get you've
got this next interaction with another
human being to make the world a
marginally better place you've got this
one opportunity to fall in love with
existence so why not relax and enjoy
your life really relax
even in the midst of struggle even while
doing hard work even under uncertainty
you are in a game right now and you
can't see the clock so you don't know
how much time you have left
and yet you're free to make the game as
interesting as possible you can even
change the rules you can discover new
games that no one has thought of yet you
can make games that you used to be
impossible suddenly possible and get
others to play them with you you can
literally build a rocket to go to Mars
so that you can start a colony there
I actually know people who will spend
some part of today doing that but
whatever you do however seemingly
ordinary you can feel the preciousness
of life then an awareness of death is
the doorway into that way of being in
the world
[Music]
okay here's a lesson titled the mystery
of bean
[Music]
of all the solar systems in this
universe that might sustain complex life
we find ourselves in this one it took
billions of years of evolution on this
earth to produce the people we now are
our brains and bodies have evolved
through millions of generations reaching
back to creatures totally unlike us to
animals so strange that we wouldn't even
want them as pets and finally two
single-celled organisms for ages the
world got on without us but now we're
here and among all the possible people
that could exist we are among the tiny
minority that actually do and of all the
periods in human history where we might
have appeared we live in this one
arguably the first in which it was
possible to understand our circumstance
in a truly universal sense for the first
time a person's view of the world need
not be dictated by the mere location of
his birth or the religion of his parents
for the first time the barriers of
language and geography have totally
fallen away at this moment you have
instantaneous access to more information
that even the greatest scholar or world
leader did a generation ago and yet on
some level we confront the same mystery
of our existence that Socrates or the
Buddha faced the fact that you are you
the fact that you exist in this moment
he is a miracle of sorts
there's something fundamentally
inexplicable about it there's no amount
of knowledge that seems adequate to
dispel the mystery of our appearance
here now whatever you know whatever you
believe whatever you have done or hope
to do you have this moment of conscious
life to contemplate you have this minute
this hour this day and it will never
come again so I want to talk for a few
minutes about the intrinsic mystery of
this circumstance it really is the
mystery of being in science and
philosophy we often claim that we're in
the business of getting rid of mysteries
and there is of course a sense in which
that's true
if we don't know why people are getting
sick for instance and we discover the
virus that's causing it well then the
mystery has been solved but there's
another sense in which mystery never
recedes and if you pay attention you can
see that it's an ever-present fact of
even the most well understood phenomena
the philosopher Bertrand Russell
described our most rudimentary knowledge
of the world as knowledge by
acquaintance
for instance the color of a table
standing before you and here's a quote
the particulars a dove color that I'm
seen may have many things said about it
I might say that it is brown that is
rather dark and so on but such
statements though they make me know
truths about the color do not make me
know the color itself any better than I
did before so far as concerns the
knowledge of the color itself as opposed
to knowledge of truths about it I know
the color perfectly and completely when
I see it and no further knowledge of it
is even theoretically possible thus the
sense data which make up the appearance
of my table are things with which I have
acquaintances and things immediately
known to me just as they are in quote
now what Russell seems to overlook here
is that this basic knowledge to which no
knowledge can even be theoretically
added is a place where we uncover an
intrinsic limit to understanding when we
consider any facet of experience in this
case a vision of color if we can then
stem the tide of our thoughts long
enough to merely observe it as it is the
fact that we're in total ignorance of
what it is can become obvious what is
the color blue not as a function of
wavelengths of light or neurophysiology
but as it is directly perceived we're
really left with nothing to say but that
it's blue which of course does nothing
to clarify things in fact it's not even
blue which is just a word it's a noise
we're making well what we see before us
is whatever it in F it is focus
this distance between concepts and
experience is a means of sneaking up on
a truth that is generally described in
Buddhism as the truth of emptiness the
idea that no thing has intrinsic
independent existence in the way that it
seems now there are many ways to come at
this insight into emptiness and frankly
this line of inquiry may be too steep
for some of you at this point so I
encourage you to return to it after you
have more experience in the practice of
meditation but it is worth reflecting on
even in the beginning the moment we
suspend the conceptual associations we
have with a given object or perception
our knowledge about it our direct
experience of it can grade into this
experience of just pure mystery we're
left with this wordless intuition of
consciousness and its contents about
which nothing more really can be said
but right now as you listen to me speak
pay careful attention to the process of
listening the feeling of sitting in your
chair look closely at everything around
you I'd like to suggest that while you
know many things about the present
moment you do not know what anything in
itself is now look at your hand what is
it we can define this part of your body
in language you can call it hand you can
consider the fact that it's made of bone
and muscle and thread it with blood
vessels and nerves but this is all a
description about the object that you're
now looking at if you simply look at
your hand and ask yourself what is it
you might realize in a moment of rare
open mindedness that it is an absolute
mystery it is in fact as mysterious and
appearance as any you could ever hope to
find now there are scientific arguments
that can be arrayed against the
mysteriousness of any object we can
point to the fact the atoms in your hand
were born billions of years ago in the
belly of a star and in fact some of
these atoms may have inhabited several
stars in succession it's even possible
some atoms that were once in the bodies
of historical figures like Churchill or
Cleopatra are now in you in fact it
might be descriptively true to implicate
the entire universe in your hand or in
any objects being what it is but no such
litany of concepts or connections can
account for the mystery that looms
whenever you just look at something
closely anything
however commonplace and realize that
while you might have volumes of
knowledge about it you don't have the
slightest understanding of what it is in
itself now others have noticed this fact
Walter Benjamin the German literary
critic stumbled upon this mystery in
Marseille after smoking hashish for the
first time he distilled it in the phrase
how things would stand the gaze and all
things really do withstand the gaze we
confront the mystery of being in every
moment but we don't notice it because
this mystery is child over with concepts
now meditation isn't about understanding
things conceptually it's the ability to
experience things more clearly
prior to concepts it is the knowledge by
acquaintance that Russell spoke of here
taken to the ultimate degree and the
more you practice it you'll find that it
really is a new form of intelligence it
leads to another way of being in the
world and one that can allow for a kind
of psychological freedom that a
continuous entanglement with concepts
doesn't there's a famous parable from
the Buddha meant to get at this
difference a man is struck in the chest
with a poisoned arrow and a surgeon
rushes to aside to begin the work of
saving his life but the man resists the
first wants to know the name of the
Fletcher who fashioned the arrows shaft
and the type of wood from which it was
cut and the motive of the man who shot
it and the name of the horse upon which
he rode and a thousand other things that
have no bearing at all upon his present
suffering or ultimate survival so this
man needs to get his priorities straight
his commitment of thinking about the
world
results from a basic misunderstanding of
his predicament and then we may be only
dimly aware of it we too have problems
that will not be solved by more thinking
[Music]
finally here's a 12-minute guided
meditation it comes a little later in
the course
[Music]
as you get comfortable in your seat you
might keep your eyes open for the
beginning of this session and take a few
deep breaths and just let yourself
settle into the feeling of resting in
space
and as you gaze in front of you just let
your gaze be as wide as possible no need
to focus on anything in particular
into space with soft eyes feeling the
breath come and go
listen to the sounds in the room horizon
and pass it away
and as you stare into your visual field
take a moment to look for what is
looking see if you can look back with
your attention at the one who was seen
now this may sound paradoxical but see
what happens the moment you look there
was a teacher named Douglas Harding who
wrote a book titled on having no head
and the exercise he recommended to his
students was to gaze at whatever is
before you and look for your own head
notice that your head is not one of the
things you see what is it like to see
the world and simultaneously notice that
your head is not appearing in it
does anything to your sense of awareness
Harding used to say that where his head
was supposed to be it was just the world
see if you can be mindful of that in
each moment
and now and gently close your eyes and
pay attention to this feeling that you
might have that you're now inside your
head your attention is in something but
again what you're calling your head the
sensations you get from your skin the
muscles in your face all of that is
appearing in consciousness that which is
aware is not inside of something
everything is in it see if you can feel
that
open your eyes again and ask yourself
what has changed is there a sense that
the world comes rushing in the space
just got bigger you might play with this
opening and closing your eyes
periodically
is there really a change there's a
change in the contents of consciousness
clearly there are things you can see
with your eyes open that you can't with
your eyes closed but you still have a
visual field in both cases when you
close your eyes your visual field
doesn't disappear
changing our the contents of
consciousness
and more and more as we proceed in this
practice we want to be looking to see if
the feeling that consciousness has a
center that there's a meditator in the
middle of each moment of meditation a
thinker of thoughts a seer of sites a
hear of sounds we'll be looking into
that that feeling that awareness
emanates from a single point inside the
head and in some ways this is even
easier to do with eyes open because we
use vision to define ourselves in
opposition to our environment more than
we do with the other senses there's a
clear feeling that most of us have most
of the time that we are behind our face
looking out at the world through our
eyes but as you look out at the world in
this moment see if that feeling is true
you might look to see if there's any
evidence as you were behind your face at
this moment
and the moment you notice you're lost in
thought come back to this exercise keep
an attention very wide with our eyes
open or closed
have seen if this feeling of being
inside the head survives scrutiny
in the last minute of this session just
give up all efforts and notice whatever
appears on its own
well today I
introduced a slightly different exercise
and there'll be some more of that coming
from time to time this is good to use
this growing facility with mindfulness
to engage a kind of structured analysis
of experience you can definitely
precipitate certain insights by doing
something a little more directed than
just noticing whatever happens to arise
and if you're interested you might get
that book I mentioned on having no head
by Douglas Harding because he in a way
that was quite unique to him developed
analogies and exercises that can provoke
an insight into the elusiveness of
subject object perception it's not to
say that consciousness isn't arising in
the brain not making any claims about
your mind being coterminous with the
rest of the physical world
what Harding was doing was showing that
this sense of being inside the head from
the side of experience changes when you
actually looked to see if it's true and
as you play with that exercise you might
find that a very expansive and
centerless sense of what awareness is
can emerge in place of this feeling that
you would otherwise call I
[Music]
okay well hopefully that gives you a
sense of what I'm doing with the waking
up course again this is an ongoing
project for me and as I had content of
the course I'll be attempting to
synthesize everything I've discovered in
my own practice and in philosophy and
science generally this seems helpful for
increasing our understanding of our own
minds of course many of these things
have been discussed by philosophers and
contemplatively for centuries
context so unlike my own podcast which
deals with politics and recent
developments and science and a host of
topical and controversial issues the
waking of course is really a chance for
me to talk about the most important
things I've ever learned so if you're
interested in practicing meditation with
me and engaging in philosophical and
scientific considerations about the
nature of mind
you can check it out at waking up calm
thank you Tim for inviting me on your
podcast your audience should know that I
consider myself not only a friend of
yours but I'm also one of your true fans
because yours is one of the podcasts
that I regularly listened to in fact
with some regularity I steal your guests
I discovered Eric Weinstein on your
podcast and he and I now have done a few
together I found will McCaskill here
along with the inimitable Jaco willing I
think there may be a few others and all
those guys became not only podcast
guests but friends as well so apart from
being grateful that you're in my life
Tim I am hugely benefiting from what you
were doing in the world so keep it up my
friend and thanks again for introducing
me to your audience hey guys this is Tim
again just a few more things before you
take off number one this is five bullet
Friday do you want to get a short email
from me and would you enjoy getting a
short email from me every Friday if that
provides a little morsel of fun for the
weekend and five bullet Friday is a very
short email where I share the coolest
things I've found or that I've been
pondering over the week that could
include favorite new albums that I've
discovered it could include gizmos and
gadgets and all sorts of weird [ __ ] that
I've somehow dug up in the the world of
the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com
that's 4-hour workweek com all spelled
out and just drop in with your email and
you'll get the very next one and if you
sign up I hope you enjoy it
I get asked all the time if you could
only use one supplement what would it be
my answer is inevitably athletic Koreans
it is your all-in-one nutritional
insurance I recommended it before our
body did not get paid for that and I
travel with it to avoid getting sick I
take it in the mornings to ensure
optimal performance it just covers all
my bases if I can't get what I need
through whole food meals throughout the
rest of the day if you want to give
athletic greens a try they are offering
a free 20 count travel pack for
first-time users I always travel with at
least three or four of these this
represents a $100 value so if you buy
athletic greens you get an extra $100
and free product so check it out
athletic greens calm forward-slash Tim
again that's athletic greens calm old /
Tim for your free travel pack with any
purchase this episode is brought to you
by the Legal Zoom which more than 2
million Americans have used to help
start their businesses pass guests even
such as Robert Pressley developer CEO
automatic Matt Mullenweg
now valued at more than a billion
dollars have used Legal Zoom to help
with their business needs specifically
in his case to form his company putz
Legal Zoom isn't just for launching your
business their services include
everything from helping you to manage
changing tax laws reviewing contracts
for creating NBA's non-disclosure
agreements important stuff handling
lease agreements and assisting with
really any other legal challenge hurdle
inconvenience that typically takes time
and effort away from running your
the best part is that you won't get
charged by the hour because Lille zoom
isn't a law firm so they won't be
running the clock up and spinning
circles just to raise your bill instead
they just ask you to page one
no upfront price for whatever it is that
you're looking to get all in cart style
so visit legalzoom.com and check out
their business section for all of their
services and if you want special savings
that's the terminology and copy that
they suggest I don't know what the
special savings is folks but it's
titillating if you want special savings
enter promo code Tim T IM at check up
capital T lowercase I am again take peak
legalzoom.com and enter promo code Tim
[Applause]